[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Hello, and
welcome to You Tube
Developer's Life.
TORU YOSHIKAWA:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE].
EIJI KITAMURA:
MALE SPEAKER: Ahoy,
me hearties.
MALE SPEAKER:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE].
RETO MEIER: This week, neither
one of us are wearing pants.
MARY GROVE: We have an
audience question.
How does that affect the way
you evaluate potential
investments, especially
at the seed level?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOUIS GRAY: Welcome
back to Google
Developers Live at I/O 2013.
We're setting up for an
exceptional Day Two of
interviews.
I'm Louis Gray.
I'm here with Daniel Sieberg.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Good
morning, Louis.
LOUIS GRAY: Thank
you for joining.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Did you go
out last night at all?
LOUIS GRAY: Oh, I don't know.
I've been working
this whole time.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah, I know.
It's true.
LOUIS GRAY: That's the fun part
of being a part of I/O.
You get to see the excitement.
All the developers have come
in around the world.
A lot of them are getting
excited about device
giveaways, new product
announcements, and parties.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
absolutely.
Last night was After
Dark, of course.
I heard the Billy
Idol showed up.
Is that true?
LOUIS GRAY: Billy
Idol showed up.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
LOUIS GRAY: DJ Aoki showed up.
I was having a little bit of
flashbacks to the early '90s
when I heard Billy Idol
was going to be there.
But that's a guy who
is really timeless.
DANIEL SIEBERG: He really is.
He seems to have aged
well, somehow.
So let's talk a little
bit about yesterday.
There was so much to digest,
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Over the
course of the keynote.
LOUIS GRAY: A 3 and
1/2 hour keynote.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
3 and 1/2 hours.
That's a lot of information
for anybody to process.
And you and I have made about
300 pages of notes on
everything that we were hearing
throughout the course
of the day.
LOUIS GRAY: I think we had
enough time yesterday to go
through like a page and
a half of those notes.
The only thing about a 3
and 1/2 hour keynote is
we got to be flex.
It's the fun of live TV and live
streaming is that we got
crunched down from our
30 minutes of prep
down to like 10.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah, yeah.
LOUIS GRAY: So we want to
definitely take time to look
at the keynote at hit the big
items that were a big summary
of the keynote.
Vic Gundotra was up there.
You had Sundar Pichai,
[? Erj ?].
You had really some incredible
people who are leading the
next generation of information
discovery, and gadgetry, and
social, and all this, and
really, some stuff I wanted to
get out of the way.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah
absolutely.
Let's talk about some
of the numbers we
heard yesterday, too.
48 billion installs.
LOUIS GRAY: 48 billion.
DANIEL SIEBERG: With Google
Play, two and a half billion
in the past month alone.
900 million installed
Android devices.
LOUIS GRAY: And that's more than
double from last year.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right.
LOUIS GRAY: And last year
when we were here,
we were at 400 million.
And I think 100 million
in 2011.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yup.
LOUIS GRAY: And so if you look
at the growth of Android, it's
just incredible.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Absolutely.
And Sundar has talked, too,
about the potential beyond
that, the 5 billion people who
are still not connected to the
internet around the world,
but will be one day.
LOUIS GRAY: Yes.
Now, he put up a slide that
looked at the globe, and you
could see the number of areas
around the world that had less
than, I think, 10% penetration
of Android.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
LOUIS GRAY: And you think about
how do you get internet,
and mobile devices, and all
these things that we take for
granted to the next 80%?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah, exactly.
LOUIS GRAY: It's really is an
incredible opportunity--
DANIEL SIEBERG: It's
really exciting.
LOUIS GRAY: --and I'm glad
Google's focused on that.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
So I'm just going through some
of my notes here, but let's
talk a little bit
about Android.
First of all, Android Studio.
LOUIS GRAY: Yes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: The development
community, I
think, really excited
about that.
Almost taking over
from Eclipse--
LOUIS GRAY: Yes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --in
some ways?
LOUIS GRAY: I saw some
interesting feedback.
One of the great things about
Google+, is you can see your
friends talk about the keynote
practically in real time.
And one of my friends was
talking about it, saying even
at a 0.1 release, Android
Studio is a significant
alternative to Eclipse.
He is very excited about that.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
LOUIS GRAY: I watched that get
rolled out in the pre-roll the
day before.
And it was exceptionally
exciting to see how they could
take things that traditionally
are complex, things like
taking an Android app and
fitting it across multiple
different phone sizes.
How do you code for something
that not only looks well in a
3.7-inch phone, but like
an 8-inch phone?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Or
a 10 inch even.
I mean, the response from people
in the audience, I
think, said it all.
The cheers that came up when
people were talking about that
cross-platform cross-device
kind of integration.
And the demo that was done
was fascinating.
And also we should talk about
the games services as well
that was announced.
LOUIS GRAY: Yes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: But to see that
ability to play a game
across devices like that, as
a long-time gamer, it was
amazing to me.
LOUIS GRAY: I think everybody
has had that situation where,
you knock out a high score
on your phone.
You get home, you open up your
Nexus 7, you're like.
I don't wan to hit
this level again.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
LOUIS GRAY: I know this level.
I mean, I could do it again.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I'm
sure I saved it.
Why is this happening?
LOUIS GRAY: But I want to
have that high score.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yup.
LOUIS GRAY: And you have
to remember which
device you're on.
You're like, well, I actually
did better on my phone than I
did on my tablet.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right, right.
LOUIS GRAY: I think a lot of
that's going away, especially
when you tie it into Google+
and your social graph.
You know how your friends
are doing.
You know how you're doing.
And it's really kind of the next
generation of multiplayer
gaming across devices.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
absolutely.
And then also within that, of
course, the All Access music
service, which I think a lot of
people are excited about,
the ability not only to stream
songs, but to create your own
playlists, radio stations,
essentially, and to upload up
to 20,000 songs of your own
content to store as well.
LOUIS GRAY: What really struck
me when the team was talking
about that is really kind of a
mix and match, the best of
both worlds.
We've had the option for a while
to have the music locker
where you could take all of your
tunes, wherever you had
them from, and put them
into the cloud.
And access them on any device.
Well, what was really missing
was connecting it first to the
Google Play Store, which
happened last year, so you
could tap into that library, and
then second, having that
streaming option, where
you can really build a
radio based on a song.
You hear a fresh track, and
you want to hit it and say
what else is going on that
I don't have yet?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
and it's essentially
like an infinite playlist.
More music comes in.
You can look ahead.
I love the interface where you
can actually swipe a song out
of the way if you want to look
ahead and don't want
to listen to it.
LOUIS GRAY: And we've
seen that.
You have other streaming
services.
You're like, gack!
How did that song get
on my playlist?
And you kind of hit
it to go way.
And that's good that's there.
And that was at $9.99
a month, right?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right,
exactly.
And although you can--
I think you can sign up in
advance for $7.99 through to
the end of June.
So that's a pretty good deal.
LOUIS GRAY: Sure.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Google Maps, I
think, got a lot of attention
here, and rightly so, and
amazing refresh and re-design
to the tool we now call the
classic Google Maps but is now
the new Google Maps.
The fact that you're able to get
this vector-based amazing
experience, the way that you
look at the Maps experience is
totally different.
I mean, you see the search
bar on the top left.
You see more of the map itself,
the suggestions from
your friends on places to
go to, all of that.
Amazing on desktop.
We saw it previewed on mobile.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Hopefully
coming soon.
LOUIS GRAY: We've been talking
about this for two years now,
with Google+ as the social layer
that's improving all the
different applications.
You look at Maps, and if you
have a significant number of
reviews, it's really going to
impact the way that you
display in a map.
If you have a place, and it's
gotten so many reviews, and
people have given it a certain
grade, like through the Zagat
scores and all that, I often
find that when I'm traveling,
I'm not going to be the expert
of restaurants in an area.
I often make silly mistakes,
like going to a national chain
when I get to a new place when
I really could have gone the
next level and found
something cool.
And with recommendations from my
friends in new places, now
that's where Maps can really
take off and have a
difference.
I think we've seen a lot of
coverage in the last year or
two about the importance
of getting Maps right.
And having Google Maps on every
device, be it in your
car, or on your phone, or
in your Glass, all these
different things, it really is
a difference maker in making
sure you have the right
information that gets you
there at the right time.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
I've worked a lot
with Geo folks.
And as you know, they have
spent years refining and
making these maps more accurate
and more useful.
LOUIS GRAY: And that's
not easy-- or cheap.
DANIEL SIEBERG: It's
a mammoth task.
Yeah, exactly.
And they've done
an amazing job.
Let's also talk about Search,
because that has been much
more sort of closely integrated
in some ways with
the Maps experience.
And we saw that Amit was
up there talking about
conversational search.
LOUIS GRAY: Yes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: This is
something that I think--
LOUIS GRAY: And [? Johan. ?]
Amit [? and Johan ?] did
a great job up there.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yup.
And the idea that you can
actually just talk to your
computer essentially, and say,
OK, Google, ask it what you
want, without even having to
tap on the microphone.
LOUIS GRAY: We had
[? Barish ?]
come up here yesterday to
talk about Google Now.
And Google Now has been
transformative to find the
information that you want,
even without you asking.
They called it Assist,
and basically take
you to the next level.
And you look at that inside your
browser, and she did a
demo saying, how far
is it from here?
And when you say how far is
"it," what is it referring to?
How far is here?
And it referred to the
previous discussion.
You're almost having a
conversation with your browser.
And the demo went off without
a hitch and talked about how
long it takes to get down to
Santa Cruz, like an hour and
21 minutes for 72 miles.
And just the idea of talking
to your computer.
You know, we talked about
this yesterday.
I know you've got young kids.
I've got young kids.
And my children really think
that they should be able to
get any piece of information
that they want out of any
device at any time--
instantly.
You know, my daughter's holding
up her Nexus 7 and
saying, show me videos
of sea turtles.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
You see, it's the
on-demand generation, really.
They want it when
they want it.
LOUIS GRAY: They
just expect it.
They'll hold it up
and say, show me
pictures of daddy, right?
And there's going to come a time
where Google understands,
oh, this is Sarah talking,
and when daddy, it
refers to this guy.
And that'll come.
I really believe that.
And it's kind of fun.
They expect it to be there.
And they should be able
to talk to their TV,
Google TV at home.
They'll pick up the remote
and talk to it.
And it's really fun to
see that develop.
And we've gone from a world of,
hey, that would be nice.
And we saw it on "Star Trek",
like Amit is talking about, to
really realizing that
we're living in the
future right now.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
I loved that "Star Trek" analogy
because I think that
really resonates with people,
especially those of us who
grew up watching sci-fi, the
fact that you could just
interact with it in that very
seamless way, that you find
and get what you want
very quickly.
And then the technology sort of
gets out of your way, and
you can carry on with
what you want to do.
LOUIS GRAY: And that's something
that's been a big
aspect of a lot of Google
services lately.
You talk about Chrome.
And people say why is
it called Chrome?
And in design, people often
called the stuff around the
browser "chrome," be it the
navigation bar, the sidebar,
the scroll bar.
And with Chrome, it was just to
get that out of the way, to
get the technology and the
browser out of your way.
And you look at the Pixel.
Both of us are lucky enough to
have Pixels in front of us
today, incredible screen
resolution.
But they said you should never
have to see another Pixel.
And they're serious
about that.
And if you can get the Chrome
out of the way, you get the
Pixel out of the way, there
should be nothing standing
between you and the information
and the people you
want to connect to
immediately.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yup, exactly.
And speaking of the Pixel, as
you mentioned they're right
here in front of us.
All of the attendees here got
one, which was obviously very
exciting for them.
They're all floating around
here today as people are
checking them out, and as you
say, discovering the amazing
screen resolution
with it, too.
LOUIS GRAY: And we actually have
the team, Chris Lyons and
Andrew [? Rogers ?] are going
to be coming here this
afternoon to talk
about the Pixel.
We are going to do
a deep dive.
We actually have an incredible
lineup for today, which we are
going to get to, which goes even
further than yesterday, I
believe, not only in the terms
of number of sessions, but the
incredible people who
we're going to have.
Everyone from Bradley Horowitz,
vice president on
Google+, to Hugo Barra from
Android and Hiroshi Lockheimer
who are just doing an
incredible job.
And we'll get to that.
But I want to talk a little bit
more about the keynote,
one of the things that really
struck me that Google's been
talking about.
We see it often because
we're internal, right?
We get to understand how Google
works and see how the
different products
come together.
And it's really an opportunity
at I/O for the covers to be
pulled back.
And for the developers and the
rest of the world to see how
we're thinking and why we're
doing what we're doing.
How are we moving away from
a world where we have many
different product areas that
possibly ship independently
and do their own thing to
something that is one Google
and it all comes together?
And one of the things I really
enjoyed was to really focus on
the fact that you should have
a unified experience on your
mobile device, on your tablet,
on your desktop.
It really should be
no different.
And there were a number of
things that clearly stuck out
to me on that.
First let's start
with Google+.
Google+ had a complete redesign
of their interface,
which is really exciting.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
I've been messing
around with it already.
I'm sure you have, too.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
We get to enjoy some of these
things ahead of time.
I enjoy having it on my consumer
account now and be
able to see all my photos
looking beautiful, to be able
to see things that are
horizontal take up the entire
page, to have really smart
hashtags that can discover new
information for me that I
wasn't even looking for.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah, that's the
idea of related hashtags
that they talked about.
LOUIS GRAY: Yes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And then the way
that the cards will flip
around within your stream.
LOUIS GRAY: They talked
about bringing depth.
Today most social networks
are flat.
You read it.
You read it from top to bottom,
and that's how it is.
And the new Google+, it really
kind of brings another level
of depth of field.
And the photo experience,
the auto enhancement--
the auto awesome, is what
they call it-- is really
incredible.
But where I was going with that
is Google+ looks the same
on mobile and desktop.
It's no longer a situation where
you have a mobile team
and you have a desktop team.
And maybe the mobile device
looks even better than the
desktop or vice versa, and you
wonder which features are on
which device.
It should all just flow.
And so on the mobile device, and
on the desktop, and on the
tablet, you have the same
rich experience.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And within that,
as you mentioned the
seamless integration of all of
these different services and
devices, Hangouts now bring
together all of those
different ways of communicating
with Chat and Talk.
And so it is a much
more integrated
experience with all that.
LOUIS GRAY: And Hangouts is an
interesting thing that you
mentioned that.
You look at text, photos, video,
three totally different
things where, previously,
you were always
looking at which app.
If I'm going to go to photos,
I have an app for that.
If I'm going to have
video, I'm going to
do something else.
And what Hangouts has done,
it's not just a simple
re-branding.
It's a whole technology refresh
to take the little
pieces that we had together in
the messaging world and bring
them together as one.
And so you no longer have to
think about, maybe this
person is on OS.
Maybe they're on Android.
Maybe this does filtering
better.
It's really all about bringing
all the conversation you have
in one place across devices.
You can see where somebody
is in a conversation.
This person's right
up to here.
You can see who's actively
typing and engaging in a group
chat, and it makes it alive
on all your devices.
So I can start a discussion on
my Pixel, close it, and then
go over to my Android device and
really see that come up.
DANIEL SIEBERG: As you know,
Hangouts are used by us
internally, of course, for
meetings all the time.
But from a personal standpoint,
they are
indispensable for me when
I'm on the road.
We talked about having kids.
I mean, I think my daughter's
growing up understanding that
once in a while daddy's in the
computer, and that ability to
kind of do that anywhere,
anytime.
I've done a mobile Hangout
with my daughter.
It's really, really
cool stuff.
LOUIS GRAY: You know, Hangouts
is really transformative.
What's cool about it,
I recently did
a trip out to Europe.
And silly me, I didn't set up my
mobile phone in such a way
that I had 4G access.
You get there, and good luck.
All you got is Wi-Fi,
but that was fine.
We're living in a world where
you don't always need to have
that type of voice capability.
I went to my computer and
fired up a Hangout.
And every single day, I spoke
to my kids face to face.
And we had that type
of relationship.
I did it last night.
After we wrapped up here,
at 7 o'clock--
great range of shows--
I went back to the hotel,
fired up Wi-Fi and
talked to my kids.
And I could see them running
around making
a mess in my office.
And really talked to
them and said, hey,
here's what I'm doing.
And they could see me
and talk back to me.
And I could tell them to shape
up, and go to bed, and do all
those things you do as a
parent, face to face.
And that's really
transformative.
DANIEL SIEBERG: It
is very powerful.
My parents live in
Canada, actually.
They've actually participated
in her birthday parties via
Hangout, just sitting and
watching and kind of feeling
like they're virtually there,
which I think is really
special for them.
So speaking of Google+--
LOUIS GRAY: Yes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --we
are actually right
next door to the--
LOUIS GRAY: Where?
DANIEL SIEBERG: --Google+
sandbox.
LOUIS GRAY: I think i saw Vic
walking around here taking a
look at us earlier.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah, exactly.
LOUIS GRAY: The team is close.
DANIEL SIEBERG: They're talking
a lot about Auto
Enhance, and as you say, Auto
Awesome, and the new Hangouts,
and the new UI, and
all of that stuff.
And so I did get a chance
yesterday to talk to some of
the partners who were there.
There were quite a number
of them, we should say.
But we got a chance to
talk to about four.
LOUIS GRAY: And I think today
is a big day for Google+ for
GDL at I/O. In addition, we're
going to talk about the
sandbox and the partners that
you spoke with really soon.
But we actually have
back-to-back interviews today.
Bradley Horowitz is going
to be on our stage.
I believe that's at
11:45 or 11:55.
He's going to come on
for a half hour.
And then we're going to talk
with Seth Sternberg, behind
Google+ Sign In, for an
additional 20 minutes.
So we're going to have a
back-to-back session with
Google+ on GDL at I/O.
But before that, definitely we
want to talk a little bit
about those partners that you
saw at the Google+ sandbox.
A unique opportunity here at
Google I/O is to bring those
developers in around the world
and put them in one place.
So what is it that
they're doing?
I mean, Google+ is still pretty
new when it comes to
developers tapping into an
API, working on Sign In.
What did you see when
you were there?
DANIEL SIEBERG: I think the
Google+ Sign In aspect was a
big part of what they're working
on and integrating
that into what they
already have.
The partners that I talked to,
Fandango, which everybody
knows is a movie ticket website;
Mashable, which is
this great news and information
website that
covers a lot of different
subjects; Voxie, which is a
neat way of learning another
language; and then Jolicloud,
which is a way of actually
finding and kind of collecting
and seeing all of your
cloud-based content in one
particular interface.
So anyway, they've really
done some great stuff.
I think that they're pushing
the envelope in terms of
thinking about Sign In,
but also Hangouts.
I don't want to give anything
away as we get into it.
But they've really done
some amazing stuff.
LOUIS GRAY: Cool.
So why don't we go ahead and run
the video that we recorded
yesterday and see what Daniel
Sieberg experienced in the
Google+ sandbox.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi, there.
I'm Daniel Sieberg with Google
Developers Live at I/O 2013.
And we are at the Google+
sandbox to talk to a number of
different partners here.
We're going to start by
talking to these guys.
If you can't tell, that's
an F for Fandango.
And I'm joined right now
by Jad from Fandango.
Jad, welcome.
So Fandango people know
for movie tickets.
But how is it tying into
Google+ and that social
experience?
JAD SANTOS: Sure.
We just recently launched
integration with Google+.
So let me just walk you
through some of the--
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
JAD SANTOS: --stuff
we've done.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Great.
JAD SANTOS: So on the homepage,
you can now go to a
movie page.
And from this movie page,
you can watch a
trailer right here.
And by watching that trailer,
it records an activity onto
your Google+ stream.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So it shows up
in my stream that I've watched
the trailer?
JAD SANTOS: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
JAD SANTOS: Right.
And once you've watched the
trailer and decided, oh, this
is a good movie.
Let's go watch the movie.
I can click Buy Tickets.
And from there, I can invite my
friends, the Metreon's just
across the street.
So inviting friends is as easy
as hovering over this and
clicking Google+.
And it will show my friends what
I'm about to watch, and
if they want to join
me they can.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So what
happens if they
click on Join Me?
JAD SANTOS: I will be able
to see that, and we can
coordinate our tickets.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All
show up together.
JAD SANTOS: Buying
together, yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Very cool.
JAD SANTOS: I'll share that.
And once that's shared, you can
go to your Google+ stream
and refresh this.
Actually, it's already shown
up there already.
So it shows up right in the
middle, which is great.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
And so let's talk a little
bit the developer side.
What has it been like to work
with the Google+ folks to
integrate all of this?
JAD SANTOS: It's been
really great.
They're really had a lot
of ideas for us, and we
integrated most of them
for the launch today.
And all throughout the
development process, they've
been there locking steps.
So we've had a lot
of help from them
getting all of this done.
And we couldn't have done
it without them.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And what about
the mobile aspect?
I assume that a lot of you are
thinking a lot about people
obviously, out on
their devices.
JAD SANTOS: Yeah.
Just like they announced on the
keynote today that you can
have an automatic over-the-air
install.
So going to here, if my friends
see that I'm going to
the movies with Fandango, if
it's not already on their
phone and they interact with
me, it will automatically
install the Fandango
app on their phone.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Great, Jad.
Thank you so much.
I feel like going to watch a
movie right now or something.
JAD SANTOS: I hope so.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Thank you.
It's been a pleasure.
JAD SANTOS: Thank you.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right now,
we're on to the letter M, and
that's M for Mashable.
And I'm joined right now by
Robyn Peterson, who is the
Chief Technology Officer--
ROBYN PETERSON: That's right.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --at Mashable.
So folks know Mashable as a site
to get all sorts of news
and information.
But from the social standpoint,
what are you doing
with Google+ in terms of
curating stories and actually
acknowledging some of
the people who are
part of this process?
ROBYN PETERSON: Sure.
So we actually view ourselves
as the most social news site
on the web.
We generate a lot of our stories
based upon what's
happening in internet
culture, right?
And a lot of the conversation
about internet culture
obviously happens on
social networks.
So it behooves us really to tie
our article pages, where
we tell our stories, into the
social networks on which
they're discussed.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yup.
ROBYN PETERSON: So what we did
with the integration with
Google+ is, we, of course, have
our Google+ share button.
If a user clicks on this, they
can obviously share a story
directly from here.
So I love this new Google
Maps announcement.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yup.
ROBYN PETERSON: When I
share it through--
DANIEL SIEBERG: So that shows
up in their stream.
ROBYN PETERSON: --it will show
up right in their stream.
If I follow this person
now, I'm actually
not the curator anymore.
Now I'm one of their
followers.
So I see that person's stream,
and I say great.
I would love to see
this article that
they're telling me about.
When they click through, they
will actually see my name up
at the top of the page saying
this is the person who shared
it with you.
So what we're doing here is
we're taking that share, that
curator, so to speak, and
weaving them right into the
narrative of the story and
making them almost as
important as the person
who wrote that story.
DANIEL SIEBERG: They're
really participating
in the whole process.
ROBYN PETERSON: They
really are.
They really are.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
fantastic.
All right, now let's move
on and talk about Glass.
ROBYN PETERSON: Sure.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And
how Mashable is
tying in with that.
It's hard to do a
demo right now.
But you can maybe walk me
through what that experience
is like when a story starts to
go viral, how somebody wearing
Glass, who's got the Mashable
Glassware, can experience that
fact that the story
is going viral.
ROBYN PETERSON: Sure.
So thinking back to this summer,
we actually released
something called Mashable
Velocity.
And what that is is a viral
detection engine.
So we have crawlers that go out,
look at all the activity
on social web, bring all that
data back, dump it into a
predictive engine, and basically
tell us what's going
viral on the web.
When we reduce that down to
Mashable stories, now we have
a pretty interesting kind of
prospect for Glassware.
So all of the users who are
now wearing Glass, if they
authenticate with the Mashable
Glassware, will receive alerts
of Mashable stories about four
hours before they go viral.
So they'll be ahead
of the game.
DANIEL SIEBERG: They're
really in the know.
ROBYN PETERSON: They
really are.
They really are.
They'll know exactly what
everyone's going to talk about
before they're talking
about it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And Mashable's
been such a great partner with
Google+ really from
the beginning.
What has that experience been
like, if you can sort of talk
me through it.
ROBYN PETERSON: It's been
fantastic for us.
We have a lot of followers
on Google+.
I think we have over 2 million
people that have +1'd us and
really follow our page.
We have a very vibrant community
that's on Google+.
So we love doing things like
this where we can better
engage that community and
actually have a little bit of
fun on the engineering
side as well.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Cool.
Robyn, thank you so much for
"hanging out", if you will.
ROBYN PETERSON: Of course.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Appreciate it.
ROBYN PETERSON: Thanks,
Daniel.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Moving on to
Voxie now, and I'm joined by
Sam from Voxie.
And maybe the best way to
describe Voxie, as far as I
understand it, is it's a way for
people to learn a language
but through their
own interests.
It pushes them in a way that
is familiar to them.
So help me understand what
Voxie's about, first of all.
SAMUEL DOZOR: That's right.
So Voxie was founded off the
concept that language learning
should be contextual.
Everybody knows how they learned
a language in high
school from a boring textbook
not geared towards their
specific interests.
Voxie wants to teach you a
language based on what you're
interested in and exactly what
your language needs are.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Cool.
So here we are on
the Voxie site.
And how does this tie in to
Google+ from a Sign In
standpoint?
SAMUEL DOZOR: Sure.
So we have an Android app, an
iOS app, and a web app.
And we want to make sure that
login and registration is as
seamless as possible.
If you have an Android phone
and you have a computer at
home, we want you to be able
to login wherever you are
without having to remember all
these different passwords.
So Google+ helped us do that.
You can go right here
and go to our login.
And along with our other login
options, we have a prominent
Google+ login, which when
clicked on asks you, OK, would
you like Voxie to
access Google?
So by doing that and hitting
Accept, we start
along the flow here.
And here's actually a great
feature of Google+ allowing us
to do over-the-air installs.
So a learner can say, hey, oh,
this is available on my
Android device.
And with the new single sign-on
feature that Google
introduced today, actually,
they'll be able to open up
Voxie on their Android device
and be logged right in
immediately.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
That's great.
So, of course, one of the big
features within Google+ is the
ability to do Hangouts.
SAMUEL DOZOR: Yes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And certainly
learning a language is made
easier when you can be
conversational about it with
somebody who also knows
it really well.
So tell me how you're tying in
Hangouts with this experience.
SAMUEL DOZOR: Absolutely, yes.
So one of our first interests
in Google+ came from our
leverage of Hangouts.
So as you said, it's important
to have one on
one time with a teacher.
And Voxie enables learners to
have these one-on-one lessons
with the teachers.
But in order to do that, we
needed a great platform to
leverage so that you can have
that video conference.
So we chose Google Hangouts.
In order to do that, our users
need to have Google accounts.
So all of our learners today,
for the millions of Voxie
users, can connect their account
to Google+, such that
they can schedule, search for
a tutor, schedule a session,
and begin learning one
on one with a tutor.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
And tell me about the experience
of working with the
Google+ development community.
How has that been so far?
SAMUEL DOZOR: It's been
a lot of fun.
I was lucky enough to
attend a boot camp.
Google was nice enough to invite
Voxie on site such that
I could work one on one
with their developers.
And it really made the
experience much more seamless
to have that one-on-one
action.
But to be honest, the
documentation worked out
pretty well for us.
We were able to implement this
with only a few weeks time.
So given we're a start-up
company and we like to move
fast, so we needed to do this
quickly, and Google definitely
worked it out for us.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Very cool.
I can barely speak English
proficiently, so I feel like I
need something like this.
SAMUEL DOZOR: Oh, absolutely.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Thank
you so much, Sam.
SAMUEL DOZOR: No problem.
Thank you.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
We finish up here with Jolicloud
, and I'm joined
right now by Tariq from
Jolicloud, founder and CEO, as
I understand it.
TARIQ KRIM: Absolutely.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So talk to me
a little bit about what
Jolicloud is first of all.
And then we can get into how
it ties into Google+.
TARIQ KRIM: Sure.
So Jolicloud is a company we
started four years ago with a
simple idea.
We felt like our lives were
moving from the computer to
the cloud, and it was
spread across so
many different places.
Now YouTube is the place where
I go and watch my videos.
I have my content on Drive.
I have photos in Picasa and
Instagram, on all these
different services.
And we felt there was no
singular interface to access
everything at once.
So we built it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
So talk me through here.
You can sign in with Google+.
TARIQ KRIM: Absolutely.
So here we'll just sign in.
And as you see, we'll
automatically see that I've
already granted all these
different services.
And I we'll be able to go and
pretty much you remember when
we use these computers, the
finder, the availabilities,
all the services I have
here that I sign on.
Let me go to Google Drive.
As you can see, I can browse
through my content.
I can also access all my content
in a very simple way.
And if I need to access specific
content, I will just
go and press and be able
to access the content.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And just to be
clear, you're not storing any
of this content.
TARIQ KRIM: We don't
store anything.
DANIEL SIEBERG: It's just
an interface to
access all of these.
TARIQ KRIM: Absolutely.
We take all the APIs from all
the different services, and we
try to make them consistent
and beautiful.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Using HTML5?
TARIQ KRIM: It's all HTML5.
Absolutely.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
OK.
TARIQ KRIM: So one of my
favorite services is actually
the integration of YouTube,
because I can not only have
access to all my previous lists
of content for the new
Daft Punk video, of course.
But if I want to share content,
I can actually share
it on my favorite site,
but also be able to
favor it right away.
And now, later tonight when I
want to go and check what I
should look at, I can go to the
Watch Later section, or
probably here--
I don't have here--
to My Favorites section
and access to mine.
So we basically give you
access to your music.
We have XFM, SoundCloud.
More services are coming
soon to all your
different file systems.
I can actually go on different
services like
Box, Dropbox, or drive.
And as you can see, the user
interface is consistent.
Think about how we used to
be on our computers.
We have our own file system.
Now we've actually translated
that into the cloud in a very
simple and seamless way.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Great.
Well, Tariq, thank
you so much--
TARIQ KRIM: Thank you so
much for having us.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --for walking
us through this explanation.
I really appreciate it.
All right.
That's going to do it from here
at the Google+ sandbox.
I'm Daniel Sieberg with Google
Developers Live.